das ist ein absoluter durchbruch der
kernfusion künstliche sonne so lautet
der name des neuartigen
kernfusionsreaktors den china jetzt in
betrieb genommen hat und sofort eine
zehn sekunden lange fusion erreicht hat
gelingt es jetzt ein neues zeitalter der
sauberen energiegewinnung einzuleiten
und zwar doch deutlich schneller als
bisher gedacht klickst uns im future
gibt es dreimal pro woche spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke verpasst ihr nichts
so sehr herzlich willkommen und teilt
das video falls ihr meint dass andere
leute das auch erfahren sollten das ist
für die fachwelt weltweit wirklich eine
sensation h ell 2m tokamak ist
einsatzfähig und wurde nach angaben der
chinesischen staatsmedien mittlerweile
in betrieb genommen und der reaktor hat
aus dem stand eine 10 sekündige fusion
geschafft im inneren des reaktors kramer
kl zwar im werden temperaturen von etwa
150 millionen grad erreicht dass es
achtung zehnmal so heiß wie das innere
der sonne atomkerne werden hier zum
verschmelzen gebracht der grund für die
aufregung die weltweit zum thema
herrscht mit kernfusion wären wir in der
lage nahezu unendlich viel sauberer
energie herzustellen
denn im gegensatz zur atom spaltung
entsteht bei der fusion weniger
radioaktiver abfall er ist weniger
radioaktiv und eine kernschmelze wie in
fukushima oder tschernobyl ist nicht
möglich
bei einem störfall hört die fusion
einfach auf und das wäre wohl der
entscheidende schritt im kampf gegen die
klimakrise
damit würden wir wohl den beginn eines
neuen technologie zeit als aus allen
leuten die fusionstechnik gibt also als
eine art heiliger gral im energiebereich
manche halten die fusionsenergie sogar
für die einzige möglichkeit die
menschheit vor einer vernichtenden
klimakatastrophe zu bewahren was steckt
wirklich hinter den erfolgsmeldungen aus
china wie funktioniert der chinesische
kernreaktor und wird er seinen
spitznamen künstliche sonne wirklich
gerecht chinas pläne in sachen
fusionsforschung sind jedenfalls ehrgeiz
sich bis 2050 möchte man in der lage
sein fusionsenergie kommerziell zu
nutzen und das wären tatsächlich der
beginn einer neuen ära forschende
arbeiten schon seit jahrzehnten daran
die sonne zu imitieren
durch die verschmelzung von wasserstoff
atom will man so energie
gewinnen so wie es eben auch auf der
sonne passiert die große hoffnung die
herstellung von billiger energie und das
in unbegrenzter menge weitere positive
aspekte durch kernfusionstechnik wird
weder die natur verschmutzt noch werden
treibhausgase in die atmosphäre
abgegeben
der entscheidende unterschied zu einem
atomkraftwerk besteht darin dass die
atomkerne in einem fusionsreaktor nicht
gespalten sondern fusioniert werden sie
verschmelzen also und dabei entsteht
jede menge energie
der ganze prozess ist nach ansicht von
fachleuten sehr viel ungefährlicher als
die atom spaltungen kernkraftwerken
denn selbst bei einem unfall setzt an
fusionsreaktor nicht die unmengen an
radioaktive strahlung frei wie ein
atomkraftwerk nach heutiger bauart und
zudem haben die radioaktiven stoffe die
hierbei entstehen eine halbwertszeit von
jahrzehnten und eben nicht von
jahrmillionen so wie es eben bei einem
atomkraftwerk der fall ist also in
jahrzehnten halbiert sich die strahlung
der radioaktiven abfälle und sie werden
sehr schnell absolut ungefährlich
dadurch die hoffnung dabei ist es eine
unerschöpfliche energiequelle zu
erschließen
auf chemischer ebene entsteht dann dabei
vereinfacht gesagt aus zwei leichten
atomen ein schweres atom die gesamtmasse
des neuen atoms ist aber geringer als
die der beiden einzelnen der rest der
masse wird zur energie und zwar nicht so
wenig ein gramm der brennstoffe könnte
in einem fusionsreaktor so viel energie
liefern wie sie bei der verbrennung von
elf tonnen kohle entsteht und das ohne
dass co2 entsteht dafür notwendig ist
allerdings eine extrem heiße umgebung
denn im gegensatz zur sonne können wir
nicht den enormen druck apps sollten der
im inneren der sonne herrscht also
erzeugen wird deutlich höhere
temperaturen als ersatz denn nur so
können sehr schwere atome wie
beispielsweise terium und tritt so
überhaupt dazu gebracht werden
miteinander zu fusionieren denn
normalerweise da stoßen die sich ab und
das führt zu gleich zu zwei ganz grossen
problemen der kernfusionsforschung zum
einen ist diese sehr teuer große
finanziellen mittel fließen weltweit in
diese technologie so auch in der eu nach
angaben der bundesregierung hat die
europäische union im zeitraum zwischen
2014 und 2020 insgesamt 2,7 milliarden
euro für ihn ausgegeben
hierbei handelt es sich um das weltweit
grösste forschungs
projekt die abkürzung steht für
international firma nuclear experiment
projektor ein internationaler
forschungsreaktor an dem übrigens auch
die chinesen beteiligt sind er soll die
kernfusion sogar zehn minuten lang
aufrechterhalten
der große haken der kernfusion dabei die
technologie ist noch lange nicht
ausgereift wird ist jemals möglich sein
mehr energie zu produzieren als
reingesteckt wird denn das ist der kasus
knaxus der knackpunkt die energie die
erst mal zur zündung benötigt wird dabei
handelt es sich um eine ganze menge denn
das plasma wird ja wirklich ultra hoch
erhitzt wird es den forschungsteams
bereits in der nahen zukunft gelingen
ein plasma strom in einem
fusionskraftwerk dauerhaft am brennen zu
halten und welches material hält den
krassen belastungen an der innenwand des
plasma gefäßes über einen längeren
zeitraum stammt die prozesse im inneren
der sonne nach zu haben ist also alles
andere als einfach denn dazu müssen
schwere wasserstoff atomen namen stream
und deuterium zueinander gebracht werden
damit diese dann letztendlich
miteinander reagieren und das obwohl
sich deren kerne abstoßen der trick
dabei eine sehr heiße umgebung im winter
projekt soll ein plasma mit einer
temperatur von 150 millionen grad
erzeugt werden und das ist deutlich
heißer als in der sonne selbst bedingt
durch den geringen druck auf der erde
doch china ist nach angaben der
chinesischen medien geben jetzt bereits
ein großes stück näher gekommen
demnach ist als wm tokamak tatsächlich
in der lage bei 150 millionen grad
celsius zu arbeiten das ist fast dreimal
so heiß wie die vorgänger-version hl2
und übertrifft bei weitem auch die
temperaturen im inneren der sonne die
bei etwa 15 millionen grad celsius
liegen klar ist aber umso heißer es ist
desto schneller bewegen sich die atome
und umso höher ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass sie aufeinander
treffen und es zu einer kernfusion kommt
genutzt wird ein starkes magnetfeld um
das heißt plasma einzuschließen und zu
verschmelzen und das passiert dem talker
markt bei dem es sich vereinfacht gesagt
um eine donath förmige vakuumkammer
handelt um sie herum elektrische spulen
das prinzip ist nicht neu sondern wurde
bereits von forschungsteams in der udssr
in den 60er jahren erprobt diese form
eignet sich demnach am besten für solche
fusions experimente denn die bedingungen
in einem topf sind einfacher und besser
zu kontrollieren als in
reformen wie etwa dem stellarator schon
seit 14 jahren seit 2006 arbeiten
chinesische forscher daran kern
fusionsreaktoren zu entwickeln chinas
fusionsforschung steht auf der
priorisierung ganz weit oben und erst im
vergangenen monat november 2020 wurde
ein nationaler technologie
entwicklungsplan vorgestellt nach dem
schlüssel technologien stark unterstützt
werden um zeitnah durchbrüche zu
erreichen
dazu gehören nicht nur die künstliche
intelligenz die luft und raumfahrt
sondern eben auch die forschung an der
fusionstechnologie so soll bis 2035 ein
industrieller prototyp entstehen bis zum
jahr 2050 will man das ganze dann in
großem maßstab kommerziellen nutzen
können im visier der fachleute steht
hier übrigens nicht nur die fusion an
sich in dem reaktor soll auch getestet
werden wie die abwärme und der
partikelstrom während des
fusionsprozesses beherrscht werden kann
doch schon jetzt hat china eben diese
erfolgsmeldung rausgehauen die china
national nuclear corporation cnnc hatte
über die sensation berichtet bei der im
forschungsreaktor bei 150 millionen grad
celsius die kernfusion zehn sekunden
lang aufrechterhalten worden ist in der
originalmeldung heißt es der talker mark
reaktor hl2 m in chengdu in der
südwestchinesischen provinz sichuan
schloss seine erste entladung am vierten
dezember ab was chinas unabhängige
beherrschung der konstruktion und des
baus trost fortschrittlicher töpfermarkt
geräte und ihre betriebs technologie
bedeutet der physiker gautschi von der
tsinghua universität in peking sagte in
einem interview mit der faust china
morning post dass der weg zur sauberen
sonnenenergie alles andere als einfach
ist demnach gäbe es zitat keine garantie
dafür dass wir all diese probleme lösen
können aber wenn wir es nicht probieren
werden diese probleme ganz sicher nicht
gelöst werden von manchen seiten kommt
aber auch eine gewisse skepsis ist
bleibt vorerst offen inwiefern es sich
hierbei um eine propaganda meldung
handelt so heißt es auf der website von
solareasy de einem informationsdienst
des max planck instituts für chemische
energie konversion
dennoch steht außer frage dass dieser
chinesische reaktor ein wichtiger
schritt hin zu einem kommerziellen
reaktor sein könnte und auch an
vollkommen
anderen techniken wird inzwischen
gearbeitet um die kampflose möglichst
schnell realität werden zu lassen bei
der nasa ist die kernfusion inzwischen
bei raumtemperatur und normalen
doppelung allerdings auch dort gibt es
einen kleinen aber entscheidenden haken
kernfusion bei zimmertemperatur ohne
plasma und starke magnetfelder anklicken
also hier anschauen und abonnieren und
zwar diesen kanal klicks und schafft es
lohnt sich und kostet ja nix also
gestand bleibt